more than half of all americans depend
on their employers to sponsor their
health insurance
but with millions now unemployed because
of a pandemic
more middle class families are now
struggling with no income
and no way to pay the doctor we lost our
corporate health insurance and
that during a global pandemic is really
not where you want to be
audrey hall was diagnosed with skin
cancer three months before losing her
job in august her work-sponsored
insurance covered her surgery
but now she's uninsured and unable to
pay for follow-up appointments
and just this week her husband was
diagnosed with covid
all around me people are losing their
lives or having long-term effects from
kovid
and so as a as a mom
as a parent as a wife as a citizen
how can we have close to half a million
people be gone and
or not have the assistance to get the
right health care
28 million americans did not have health
insurance before the pandemic
now that number has grown by an
estimated 5 to 10 million
biden's executive order will allow some
of those people
to buy government subsidized health
insurance
through the affordable care act of all
times
that we need to reinstate access to
affordability of and extent of
access to medicaid is now in the middle
of this covert crisis
but the help won't reach all those who
need it in fact
audrey hall says the affordable care act
plans are still
too expensive for her family and they
don't qualify for government programs
intended for the poor
they'll remain in the gap of the
uninsured middle class
every family should be able to get a see
a family doctor whenever they need to
that should be a commitment that our
society can make to every family in this
nation
leaders in washington have pledged time
and again to reform the health care
system
but for years they've failed experts say
with the pandemic
raging the need for action is more clear
than ever heidi joe castro al jazeera